[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing albus dumbledore gellert
grindelwald and their plan to rule over
the muggle world with fantastic beasts
three well on its way i think that we
can reasonably expect to see a side of
dumbledore that we've never seen before
a glimpse into his past that outlines
his at one time questionable morality
his plan for establishing wizarding
dominance and his relationship with the
dark wizard gelet grindelwald if you
don't know dumbledore's backstory and
you've only seen the harry potter films
then let me summarize it quickly
dumbledore wasn't always good like
everyone else the wise all-knowing
hogwarts headmaster also had to face
some demons before discovering who he
truly was as a young man dumbledore
showed a lot of promise he was an
extremely innately talented wizard and
while studying at hogwarts his
professors claimed he could do things
with the wand that they had never seen
before after graduating from hogwarts in
june 1899 albus returned to his home of
godric's hollow to be with his family
after the death of his mother kendra
dumbledore albus being the eldest
sibling knew that he would have to take
care of his younger siblings
particularly ariana who had problems
controlling her magical abilities it was
during this time that albus met galet
grindelwald a young man who had moved to
the small village to live with his aunt
patilda bagshot a woman that happened to
be a family friend of the dumbledores
and grindelwald's great aunt immediately
recognizing each other's magical prowess
and amazing magical capabilities the two
boys hit it off and that's when their
scheming began you see grindelwald who
had been expelled from durmstrang was
certainly a morally questionable
character after becoming close with
dumbledore he shared with him his plans
to overthrow the international statute
of secrecy hoping to establish a new
world hierarchy in which wizards were
placed above mughals as the two grew
closer and closer dumbledore became
equally as passionate about this plan
and the two eventually coined the term
for the greater good which suggested
that wizarding rule would eventually
benefit everyone in the summer of 1899
when dumbledore was just 17 years old he
wrote grindelwald a letter discussing
their plans the letter shows dumbledore
speaking in a tone so unlike what we're
accustomed to the same letter was
published in rita skeeter's the life and
lies of albus dumbledore gellet your
point about wizard dominance being for
the mughal's own good this i think is
the crucial point yes we've been given
power and yes that power gives us the
right to rule but it also gives us
responsibilities over the ruled we must
stress this point it will be the
foundation stone upon which we build
where we are opposed as we surely will
be this must be the basis of all our
counter
we seize control for the greater good
and from this it follows that when we
meet resistance we must use only the
force that is necessary and no more this
was your mistake at durmstrang but i do
not complain because if you had not been
expelled we would never have met
albus anyway with fantastic beasts 3 on
the way i thought it'd be fun to start
diving into gelat and albus's pasts
particularly assuming we'll have a lot
of this available to us on screen that's
it for today's video if you enjoy the
content please like the video and
subscribe to the channel until next time
we want only freedom freedom to be
ourselves the disapproval of cowards is
praise to the brave
you